У неділю одразу кілька джерел поділилися фото і відеокадрами
з колоною автомобілів, схожих на автозаки ОМОНу Росгвардії,
що рухаються начебто до кордону з Білоруссю.
При цьому вантажівки не мають номерів, а люди всередині -
у чорній формі без пізнавальних знаків.
Загроза "російського втручання" у Білорусі
тематизується у низці провідних видань Німеччини.
Прохання Лукашенка до Путіна про підтримку, заяви Москви про готовність вирішити проблему
- все це мимоволі пробудило в німців спогади про події 2014 року в Україні.
Збройне втручання Росії оглядачі, однак, вважають наразі малоймовірним.
Досі на протестах у Білорусі відносини з Росією ролі майже не відігравали.
Жоден з політичних опонентів президента, який
користується відчутною популярністю у Білорусі,
не хоче руйнувати чинну зовнішньополітичну конфігурацію. У Москві це теж зафіксували.
Онлайн-портал "Медуза" в інтерв'ю зі Світланою Тихановською наприкінці липня так і не зміг
добитися від неї засудження російської анексії Криму -
навіть попри те, що вона проти союзного договору з Росією.
Віктор Бабаріко, ще один популярний опозиційний кандидат,
заявив у червні, що розірвати союз з Росією просто так не можна.
До свого затримання він очолював "Белгазпромбанк" -
доньку російського "Газпрому". Для Москви це є доказом його прагматизму.
Якщо Лукашенко буде змушений піти у відставку,
ці помірковані, з російської точки зору, кандидати
швидко стануть співрозмовниками Москви.
Пряме втручання в події у сусідній країні лише послабило б російську позицію в Білорусі.
Видання Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung  коментує:
Для росіян Білорусь - не таке овіяне міфами місце, як Крим,
який змогли "повернути додому" в 2014-му.
Тодішні натужні розповіді для виправдання,
на кшталт порятунку населення від "фашистів", сьогодні б виглядали ще менш правдоподібними.
Захищаючи Лукашенка, Путін ризикував би зіпсувати імідж Росії в очах білорусів.
У тому числі через те, що в лукашенківській теорії про начебто зовнішню змову
з допомогою місцевих осіб з кримінальним минулим у Білорусі мало хто вірить.
Навіть якщо безпорадний Лукашенко, схоже до Януковича,
по кілька разів на день телефонує з Москвою, експерти бачать
суттєві відмінності з українською Революцією Гідності.
Білоруси борються не за наближення до Європи.
У цьому відмінність від ситуації в Україні. Крім того,
захоплення Білорусі для Росії є затратним.
Не важливо, чи майорять там прапори ЄС, чи ні -
Росія все одно бачить у Білорусі частину "русского мира".
Експерти в Москві кажуть, що військовий сценарій хоч і ймовірний,
Лукашенко штовхає Росію на небезпечну авантюру.
Він намагається звернутись до Росії як до останнього оплоту,
зберегти власну владу хоч у якомусь форматі.
Зрозуміло, що це гірший сценарій для нього, але, мабуть, останній реальний.
Так, це можливо. Це буде приводом для введення якогось військового контингенту.
Це дуже небезпечна гра. Небезпечна для Росії. Це не Донбас, це не Крим.
Мало хто чекає БТР з російським прапором на борту.
Ми зіткнемося з партизанщиною і агресією в бік Росії.
У Євросоюзі минулого тижня вже домовилися про санкції для осіб,
відповідальних за насильницьке придушення протестів.
Цієї середи оголошено ще одну термінову відеоконференцію ЄС щодо Білорусі,
де мають ухвалити список санкцій та конкретний план подальших дій.
Глава Німеччини закликав Лукашенка відмовитися від насильства.
По всій країні громадяни вийшли вчора на вулиці й зажадали політичних змін.
Я захоплююся їхньою мужністю після того насильства, яке ми спостерігали в останні дні.
Я закликаю президента Лукашенка стати на шлях переговорів
s робити ставку не на насильство, а на діалог.
Я закликаю силові структури Білорусі не брати на себе гріх насильства проти власного народу.
Громадяни цієї країни, яка пройшла крізь багато випробувань,
гідні нашої солідарності й підтримки.
У 2014-му Штайнмаєр відіграв важливу роль на переговорах
між протестувальниками на Майдані і режимом Януковича.
Нині оглядачі також пропонують шукати впливову особу,
з якою був би готовий до діалогу Лукашенко.
У цій ситуації швидкі дії ЄС можуть стати вирішальними.
Брюссель мусить ловити режим Лукашенка на слові, що він готовий до переговорів,
На думку експертів, ситуація перебуває в розвитку,
і якщо Москва нині й уникає відкритого втручання, то згодом все може змінитися.